some of you may be familiar with the
right wing musical artist who goes by
the name kid rock kid rock uh has
developed a friendship of some kind with
the former president donald trump
including playing golf etc he was
recently interviewed by tucker carlson
the the interview is bizarre tucker
carlson's appearance and demeanor during
the interview are
extremely strange but the big revelation
from the interview is kid rock claims
that donald trump would ask him about
foreign policy advice and about tweets
that he was imminently going to send out
related to relationships with foreign
countries and the like now we're going
to look at kid rock uh explaining this
to tucker carlson but i think one one
important thing to keep in mind is
i doubt
that kid rock was the least qualified
person to give donald trump advice on
policy i like did it's outrageous that
kid rock was put in that position but
there were probably equally unqualified
people and at least kid rock seems to
recognize how absurd it was for him to
be pulled into this stuff so let's jump
into the interview here meet trump
let me trump oh god at the white house
sarah palin
sarah palin asked him to uh it was
friendly with her and
early right when he got elected he
invited her to dinner to bring some
interesting people right so she said she
called me and and ted up to nugent and
was like hell yeah
ended up there we ended up becoming
buddies and spent a lot of time in the
golf course now and
it's really weird get phone calls from
and stuff it's it's kind of mind-blowing
what's he like to play golf with
awesome
so much fun really why
he just knows how to have fun doesn't
take it too seriously yeah you know he's
engaging
so it's just you're just cutting it up
just open with politics and i was there
with him one day when he ended the
caliphate right he wanted that incred
the one day when the cat the the entire
caliphate ended you guys remember that
day right about a tweet and it was like
i don't like to speak out of school i
hope i'm not but it was something like
he's like
tell him like yeah the tweet was and i'm
paraphrasing but it's like you know if
you ever join the caliphate you know and
try to do this you're going to be dead
he goes what do you think i go
awesome right yeah tweet that out i was
like i can't add anything better than
that but then it comes out and it's very
it's reworded and more political and
like you know a little politically
correct and i'm like just being
brilliant we're looking at maps
i'm like you know i'm like am i supposed
to be like you know
so
uh very very trustworthy that trump with
uh classified insensitive information as
we all know remember hillary's emails
and all that
i make dirty records sometimes
i do it here you didn't think you'd have
a hand what do you think we should do
about north korea i'm like
what
i don't think i'm qualified to answer
this
at least kid rock knew he wasn't
qualified at least at least and tucker
just finds it hilarious and it's funny
how
if any of these types of folks
had like an inside line to joe biden and
the oval office and were even on the
periphery of anything substantive
tucker wouldn't be laughing the way he's
laughing he'd be calling for an
impeachment
[Laughter]
how does he how does he see you're still
playing golf with him down in florida
yeah yeah how's he seem what's that
how's he seem
he seems great he seems great you know
after the election it was you know a
little you know a little different there
and
but
he's still the same guy
he sits down he just cuts it up
just starts cutting it up it's just how
sharp he is is incredible and you can
see now if you watch
a joe biden interview and you watch a
trump interview you're just like there's
there's no comparison now that is true i
mean you you guys remember all of the
incredibly astute and articulate and and
just the clarity with which trump would
speak and god bless
the united states take a look at the
oranges of the investigation the noise
causes cancer right you guys are you you
remember all of that stuff and just
always just so clear and concise and it
all made sense so this is pretty
dangerous and it also exposes the double
standard of course that like i said
um if i mean listen during the
presidency
jared and ivanka everywhere ivanka
sitting in for rex tillerson once at a
meeting
at least once that we know about
if
you know
hunter biden if hillary clinton had been
president
uh and and her daughter had been in any
way involved in the presidency these
very people would be going
bananas
arguing this is criminal and it's all
gonna and meanwhile you know kid rock
ivanka jared kushner what they just
don't care and it's uh yet another one
of these incredible double standards
one of our longtime sponsors is vincero
collective if you don't know vincero yet
it's the place to go for quality watches
sunglasses and more
serious style
undeniable quality and total versatility
put vincero really at the top of the
game and their newest watch release
is no exception it's the argo automatic
it spotlights everything i love about
vincero i got the argo automatic in
frost white this is a dive watch which
is of course a staple in the watch world
but i really think vincero found a way
to make this one stand out i love the
gradient blue accent of the hour markers
against the solid white face i really
love all of their watches and i own a
bunch but the argo is probably my
favorite so far vincero sunglasses and
jewelry and other accessories are
awesome too
an excellent way to elevate any outfit
vincero collective is giving my audience
fifteen percent off all products and
free shipping go to
vincerocollective.com
pacman and use the code pacman the link
is down below